so I'm not gonna lie I cheated again I
actually chose two characters to be my
number one spot and I know that's a
cop-out but I just can't help it
I love these two characters so much
individually I couldn't choose between
the two of them the tie for my number
one favorite character is and a kiss
from tequila Mockingbird and Margie from
Fargo they're both incredibly different
but in many respects they're actually
very much alike each one show a great
deal of strength but also a great deal
of restraint a great deal of power but
also a great deal of kindness and both
fight as hard as they can for the very
simple basic human virtues that they
hold so dear to them Atticus Finch is
the father of our main character scout
he represents a black man who's charged
with beating a white woman even though
all the evidence points to that he
didn't do it but in a very racist town
at a very racist point of history that
argument is not so easily made
Atticus not only stands up and
represents him but takes pride in doing
so with complete class dignity and honor
despite the fact that very few people
support him and many of them threaten
his life ways up there making his case
you can see that there isn't a doubt for
any moment that he believes every single
word he's saying
he stands by that this life is anybody's
life the only difference is the hatred
being held against him which Atticus
Finch is trying so desperately to fight
against and is forced to talk to adults
like children as well as talk to his
children like adults Margie is a little
bit of a different hero
she's a chipper cop in Fargo assigned to
a murder case and uses all her
intelligence and detective know-how to
try and crack it all while keeping an
optimistic and smiling point of view as
well as being seven months pregnant she
asked the tough questions works as hard
as she can puts up with people taking
her seriously or not taking her
seriously and all with the most cheerful
grin and upbeat attitude where many
could see her as kind of a comedic care
during a time she sort of is we realized
that all these people who think they
have it figured out with their brilliant
schemes
actually light-years behind what this
woman has figured out already that
simple pleasures are the greatest
treasures and while her life may not be
glamorous it's better to focus on the
things you do have as opposed to the
things you don't both characters seem to
hold they're very simple values close to
them and both seem to fight endlessly
for them whether they realize they're
fighting for them or not their
differences are fun to compare as well
Atticus he's very stone face and firm
while Margie seems very smiling and
pleasant but while Atticus is never one
to resort to physical violence Margie
being a cop inevitably has to both of
them come from worlds with their
environments try very hard not to take
them seriously but nevertheless they
stick to their guns improve their honor
they both fight against the excuses of
society that's a maybe this bad thing is
good but both of them trust their gut
and go up against such complicated hate
with such simple ethics so simple that
you're always shocked at the end that it
has to actually be explained to some
people that this isn't just common sense
for everybody that no matter how hard
the haters may yell it doesn't make them
any more right these are the quiet
heroes the heroes that don't look for
trouble but will still fight against it
the heroes that don't have a lot of
money but still feed off of so many
rewards the heroes that know the
simplest questions often have the
simplest answers the heroes who don't
need to journey far in order to find the
great joys in life the heroes that know
that true wealth lies in mere
appreciation these are characters that
obviously love the right things and
fight for the right things and teach the
right things and never asked for any
fame or glory in return simply because
they don't need it what they have is
perfect enough in all their
imperfections and I don't think there's
any other word I can use to describe
these two characters than perf
much as these to see their lives I value
them I admire them I constantly learn
from them and I will never stop loving
them Atticus and Margie my all-time
favorite characters have you ever seen
anything more beautiful
heck no me no we're doing pretty good